I mean we got a pope that brought a a
South American Idol into the church to
worship really he did the patcha mama so
he brought that in yeah into the Vatican
then the Hier he the hierarch even
worshiped that they had a ceremony
around it outside what well that
constitutes apostasy it's that's an
apostasy move right worshiping false
gods yeah that's number one on the
Mosaic hit list so it's an inside job
so you remember not that long ago we had
this clip of Mel Gibson on Joe Rogan and
it was kind of a long clip so I I kind
of picked some parts out of there to as
talking points about uh Passion of the
Christ and and Mel Gibson talking about
um Jesus you know going to hell to
preach to the the PE well watch the
episode yeah into all that it kind of
blew up on our Channel and the comment
section blew up as well so and and just
for clarification that wasn't to I'm not
we don't do this to put people in a bad
light we're not like trying to throw
dirt on M Gibson or anything like that
and just kind of discussing he's making
this film this is what's in it and talk
about the Theology of that so anyway I
want to show you another clip from here
because it's talking about something uh
more specifically Catholic so if you
heard of Vatican 2 mhm okay so he's
going to hit on Vatican 2 and some some
issues around that so here we go and
when you asked what's the difference
between prev Vatican 2 so Vatican 2
happened and of course they they took
the church and they they reformed it and
they changed things in it and it didn't
necessarily agree with everything that
went before
it and up to that point yeah you could
find it agreed with itself but all of a
sudden you got something else to the
point where now I
mean I mean we got a pope brought a a
South American Idol into the church to
worship really he did the patcha mama he
bought the South and he got what I don't
know what that is it's a it's kind of
like a South American God patcha mama
and why would he do
that good question but he did did he
have an explanation for why he did it
yeah it's kind of a weasel worded thing
of like oh all religions are just as
good as one another but you know if
that's his contention he shouldn't be
the Pope no I mean how can you be the
popee if you say all religions are just
as good yeah we all worship you know so
yeah that's Pam Mama there you go so he
brought that in yeah into the Vatican
then the Hier he the hierarch even
worshiped that they had a ceremony
around it outside what well that
constitutes apostasy it's that's an
apostasy move all right worshiping false
gods yeah that's number one on the
Mosaic Hit List you know Moses goes up
on the mountain he comes back down
people are worship him in a golden calf
yeah you know it's it's that yeah so you
can't do that and uh for me that's a
departure
from well you know that's called
apostasy it's a falling away from and
the Very nature of apostasy means that
you have to be part of it to fall away
from it mhm so it's an inside job wow
that was a pretty heavy statement wow
Inside
Job revealing I would agree with him I
would too yeah he's almost you know you
you think it's almost sounds like he's
echoing 2 Thessalonians chapter 2 right
right because you know it it it alludes
to the the Antichrist power being a part
of the the the faith you know and it's
like you know used to walk with us and
it's come out and you know anyway that's
that was kind of some of my takeaway so
yeah Joe Rogan do you know anything
about Joe Rogan I mean I he's one of the
most popular YouTubers um outside of
like him being a conservative minded
person he he he does he does portray
that he's really genuinely searching for
truth it appears that way and he used to
be kind of a atheist I guess from what
I'm reading and uh he's become a lot
more vocal about faith and says the
world needs Jesus and these kind of
things again not to be critical of Mel
Gibson but that was kind of my first
thought too is you're you're picking on
this one thing but then there's some
other things in Catholic ISM that way
probably might not even know about you
know maybe maybe not I don't know he
seems like he's able to speak to the
issues but I think it's neat to see that
something's irking him about it you know
what I mean and then he's willing to
actually address that and maybe
hopefully a good some of those things
will come more readily to him or
something yeah this is what came to my
mind would you mind reading it James you
shall not make for yourself a carved
image any likeness of anything that is
in the heaven above or that is in the
earth beneath or that is in the water
under the Earth you shall not bow down
to them nor serve them for I the Lord
your God am a jealous God visiting the
iniquity of the fathers upon the
children to the third and fourth
generations of those who hate me but
showing Mercy to thousands to those who
love me and keep my Commandments amen
yeah and so you know when he was
mentioning that I'm thinking well but in
the Catholic Ten Commandments like that
is not
there Tak it out and that doesn't seem
to be an an issue anyway but yeah again
he could be waking up he could be having
this whole religious Epiphany I don't
know but that's where my mind went is
like you know we can pick on one thing
but there's all kinds of things to pick
on but fascinatingly he talked about
Vatican 2 do you know much about Vatican
2 so the Vatican basically is rebranding
I guess think kind of coming coming as
like okay maybe we did some really bad
stuff in the B back so it's a real big
dismissal of you know we're not like
that anymore we're going to be like this
my understanding is it's a very
ecumenical movement it's trying to bring
all of the other faiths in which is
interesting that's that that U Mel
Gibson was referencing that that God
because recently the pope was also seen
with the witches Stang which that was
nuts yeah that was actually nuts it was
you guys brought that up on a show or I
remember where came out app episode
that's right that was wild but that's my
understanding of it it was an ecumenical
movement but uh my understanding is also
that they are trying to publicly look
like they've changed but they actually
haven't changed yeah okay yeah that's
pretty good anything that you want to
throw in there well it's interesting you
know uh from the Bible we know that God
does not change you know his law is
reflective of his character and he says
I change not mhm but also Revelation
reveals the beast power first Beast of
Revelation 13 as having leopard likee
spots mhm so it's interesting that the
Beast you know can a leopard change its
spots if talking about a change
fundamentally if this power is is the
leopard it's not going to change really
it's just going to Veil it in a
different way but it's not changing yeah
Vatican 2 happened after Pope John the
23rd was elected which is a
contested um papal election even Mel
Gibson in another part of that interview
brings this up because there was black
smoke you know which was uh supposed to
be white there was actually there was
the white smoke which says okay we have
a pope mhm and then there was black
smoke I guess within a short period of
time I don't I don't know remember if
it's like a half an hour later or
something and it was like okay well
there's whoever was selected got
deselected or something like that so
he's kind of talking about this whole
thing like what's going on here like is
the real
Pope really this guy or is it supposed
to be somebody else and there's a
movement in Catholicism that say
uh the the papacy's uh seat is vacant
and has been since that time they don't
believe that a real Pope has been on the
throne I would like to have a camera in
that room why can't we see yeah why
can't we see them picking one what are
they doing in that room that they don't
want to show anybody I like what you
said there um I mean unless it's uh it's
uh the black pope that has I mean I
don't know I see a pope out there I see
Pope frsc it seems to me like there is a
pope
but we know that the black pope really
is in power which is a Jesuit Pope as
well which is a secret society that's
run by the Vatican got a whole video on
that if you want to watch that but um
yeah that he's actually in power and he
is the general the Pope Francis is just
the face yeah anyway getting off a
little bit of track but Vatican 2
happened after his election so somewhere
in like the early 60s through about 1965
they
met several times out of that was
produced like 16 documents and and four
major themes and and things like this
but Huffington Post around an article
that said Vatican 2 changed the Catholic
church and the world so here is what
they said Scotty you want to read that
the shift included the Catholic Church's
attitude toward other religions before
Vatican 2 Catholics weren't supposed to
visit other denominations houses of
worship the Catholics looked down to the
other down on the religions and thought
of them as condemned to hell but one
document from the council acknowledged
these desperate faiths have a common
belief in God said Ryan who described it
as nothing less than a revolutionary
approach it's kind of alluding to what
Mel Gibson had had he's like this is
apostasy here we are you know but part
of Vatican 2 was this real ecumenical
push like you alluded to and some of
that came when you think about
historically what's going on in the
early 60s What's Happening Here in the
states a lot of like revolutionary type
stuff right
it's Rights Movement it's counterculture
it's it's you know you free love and all
this kind of stuff is is flowing into
society one of the things that
Catholicism came under heavy scrutiny
for was
anti-Semitism and so they're trying to
find a way to be like we don't want to
appear to be anti-semitic and you have
the whole Jewish Palestinian conflict
that's you know also playing into this
and then Muslims and they're like okay
how do we
Define our relation to other belief
systems and obviously they don't want to
look like the bad guy well I find
interesting that you bring up this
ecumenical aspect because the the
Catholic church was once the World
Church like like everywhere like you
were only Catholic there were no other
denominations that is until the
Reformation happened where Protestants
like marttin Luther and zwingley out of
which many different denominations came
those people and many other people uh
start standing up and and you know start
saying you know what we don't actually
think that some of the stuff you teach
is biblical we actually think there's a
lot of paganism mixed with Christianity
and we want the Bible and the Bible
alone Etc um but then the whole purpose
of the Catholic church was like no no no
you need to come back to us the mother
church right and that's when they also
instituted the Jesuits which again like
I said is a secret society that they
were the sole purpose was to uh creep
into other churches and and act like
they're Protestants to plant seeds to
bring you back and now you're seeing it
again it's The ecumenical movement of
like well how can we bring people back
into the Catholic Church let's just
befriend everybody and hang out with
everybody exactly and if that the power
in the Bible is being identified as
Babylon and Babylon is this
conglomeration of all religions and and
mixtures of these different ideas and it
makes sense that they would take a more
open approach and then essentially
everybody's Catholic doesn't matter what
you are anyway I want to deviate from
this a little bit and talk about this
document because part of Vatican 2 was
this declaration on religious
freedom okay so I read this whole thing
yesterday
took a little while to get through it
and when you read this there's very
little in here that you would find
yourself disagreeing with it reads a lot
more like the United States Constitution
when it comes to religious liberty so
you're like scratching their head there
is one phrase James do you remember what
it was it's like um when he's talking
about religious liberty it's like to uh
do limits or something like that yes
they include a uh a statement that
sounds like it's pro-religious liberty
but then they add the qualifying phrase
within due limits yeah within due limits
so wait wait unpack that a little bit
what does that mean uh well I guess
before we unpack that the question is
who defines the limits so the statement
reads this Freedom means that all men
are to be immune from coercion on the
part of individuals or of social groups
or of any human power in such wise that
no one is to be forced to act in a
manner contrary to his own beliefs
whether privately or publicly whether
alone or in association with others
within due limits so as long as you're
within our boundaries second you step
out of our boundaries you can no longer
think like that exactly so you read this
whole thing and it sounds very very very
pro-religious Liberty very pro-religious
Liberty but when I was digging in around
I'm like obviously there's controversy
around this thing so what is the problem
what do people have an issue with go to
the na National Catholic register okay
which is a um Catholic um very Catholic
Source um and I think they're a paper
are they a paper probably like a
publication
yeah it says in this article set
standard for defending religious freedom
so when we go here what do we read
Anique would you mind reading that
dignis Humane teaches that no person
should be coerced by any human agent in
matters religious religious freedom in
short constitutes an immunity from
coercion in Civil Society Thomas far the
director of the religious freedom
project at Georgetown University which
is a Jesuit university told the register
however this does not mean that the
church is indifferent to the way a
person exercises his freedom to the
contrary dign is Humanity does not
change the church's teaching on who she
is the church left by Jesus For All
Mankind and what is required of us it's
one of the interesting things that comes
out of this is they line that they draw
they're helping interpret what does this
thing mean when the church is talking
about religious freedom and they
referred to this uh Georgetown James
sent me an an article from um a guy who
wrote up on this at Georgetown and it's
very interesting there was kind of like
three different positions when it came
to religious
freedom
but they in that article it basically
said that error has no freedom
so now you're getting into the realm of
well what is the truth and who's
defining the truth and
essentially they're the ones that are
defining the truth and when they're
talking about religious freedom what
they're trying to do is set themselves
up apart from the state and say we are
as a church declaring ourself that we
need to be free from hindrances and and
people need to be free from hindrances
of the state the state should protect
religion but in matters of religion were
the sole Authority M so they're and not
the Bible putting themselves above so
here's another interpretation um on this
document the RFI blog religious freedom
Institute I think it was talking about
this as well says the 19th century popes
called for the state to coorse to issue
legal directives backed by threats of
punishment in support of religious truth
and against religious error and to
enforce the laws of the church this is
kind of the picture that most everybody
remembers of Catholicism especially for
Inquisition and things like that so like
when you think of religious uh
persecution and religious intolerance
kind of the Catholic Church of the
Middle Ages comes to mind right it goes
on it says but 1965 in uh dignus Humane
Vatican 2 taught something that appears
quite opposite when you read it I'm
telling you it looks like total
religious freedom that we have a right
not to be coerced in our religious
activities by the state except where the
state needs to protect just public order
because the state lacks the authority to
coer religiously okay we go on one of
the two Powers has for its proximate and
chief object the well-being of this
Mortal life the other the Everlasting
joys of Heaven whatever therefore in
things human is of a sacred character
whatever brings either of its own nature
or by reason of the end to which it is
referred to the Salvation of souls or to
the worship of God Falls holy within the
power of the church and is Holy subject
to her judgment not Gods the church so
there's something further though in the
same document this is a mortalite day
from Pope Leo VII in November 1st 1885
where they go on to state that the
unrestrained freedom of thinking and of
openly making known one's thoughts is
not not inherent in the rights of
citizens and is by no means worthy of
favor and support so even your thoughts
can get you in trouble freedom of
thinking unrestrained is not to be
supported interesting yeah it's kind of
a it's it's it's really when you look at
it nothing's really changed they've just
changed the way it's massaged more or
less so the out the the documents that
are that are out there basically say you
should be free to seek and
worship God as you see fit and your
family but really there's only one
choice and that choic is the Catholic
church and we're going to Define what
truth is for
you so same restaurant just different
logo I mean really and you kind of wrap
this thing up and it says this is kind
of the conclusion of this whole document
so this this uh dignitas himman strict
teaching about the authority of the
state
not the church and far from
contradicting 19th century papal
teaching the Declaration recognizes and
makes explicit what Leo the 13th's two
power Theory implies for the moral
rights of the individual against the
state in matters of religion once the
state has become
secular wow so that was
um yeah that was really what that whole
thing
is is about so on the outside you know
and I can imagine how confusing this
this would be and this is why you know
we're not coming down on people like me
Gibson I kind of Wonder even in the
church
itself it he's looking at it like well
this whole thing uh changed and it's and
it's different I wonder how many
Catholics really do understand that a
lot of this isn't just that different
like it's been reworded and repackaged
in a way that looks really nice and
pleasing but you look at even their own
people that are interpreting some of
this stuff or religious institutes and
they're saying nothing's really changed
it's still the same it's still that has
the ability to be that religious
persecuting power yeah the church is
defining the morality I mean it's
interesting that it wasn't like based on
the Bible you know like on what the
scriptures say yeah I like what John
8:36 says if the sun makes you free you
shall be free indeed right and that
doesn't tie you to a a church or an
institution or an organization it's it's
tied to Jesus your freedom is found in
Christ alone mhmh you know in some ways
though the devil has to unify his forces
against the remnant at the end of time
so he has to support some kind of
agreement between them or or means of
putting down the peace and one of the
ways that I think digitat San is
actually reflected in Catholic uh
I guess art and and Doctrine and pushes
is actually a a model by venzo pandoli
and we talked about this before on the
Jesuit episode where you've got this one
Central Church and all these other
denominations are encircling around it
and it's like it's almost like what
Revelation describes where you've got
this mother church and you've got all
these daughters so long as you agree
with that mother church and accept her
Authority in spiritual matters you have
freedom to you know certain freedom to
to say what you want but the minute that
you step out outside of that then you're
deemed a heretic and and you see this
too with uh all the presidents and world
leaders that come and show up to the
Pope I mean we we mentioned this before
off off camera that um at one point
Trump made some remark about the pope he
was joking about the pope or something
but lo and behold when he gets voted in
he's standing there and he's making a
visit I mean they're all doing it and
they're not all doing it to some otherr
leader is just the pope right it's wild
when you see those videos of all these
like famous world leaders and stuff like
that all coming and visiting him they
recognize him as a man of authority and
of power but it's like but he is a
religious person why is he showing up at
all your very political events and all
your political meetings with all of the
world leaders what does he have to do
with that what does he know about the
economy I like how Christ All Through
the Bible um is the the source of
religious liberty you look at the Garden
of
Eden he offered them a choice it wasn't
coion it wasn't anything like that it
was like look you can choose and he has
allowed Humanity continue to choose it
doesn't mean that your choices won't
have consequences they'll have
consequences but Christ all throughout
the human history has allowed us to
choose and that's why I believe that
James refers to God's law is the law of
Liberty you know um we can choose it
doesn't mean that we're always going to
make the right choice but Christ has
instituted religious freedom for every
person to say you know what the choice
is up to you you decide mhm not only
that but he's also said that vengeance
is mine I will repay that's right so
when there's people who diverge from
truth it doesn't require the state to
come along and say well we're going to
persecute these Heretics God is the one
that will step in and correct matters he
can actually take care of it he knows
what to do exactly yeah all right well
thank you all for watching we hope that
you will appreciate this um and check it
out some more I mean we didn't do
anything exhaustive on Vatican 2 we may
do something in the future with James
and and look into that a little more but
I hope that you appreciate your
religious freedom no matter what Walk of
Life you're coming from and so make sure
you give this video a thumbs up a like
share it with somebody who may need to
see it and we hope to see you next time
in another episode of LED live take care
oh
[Music]